hello I'm Greg Sadler I'm Matthew
Sadler's father and he asked me if I'd
record a video for you his music class
about the banjo that has been in our
family for a long time belong to my
father belongs to me now and I may be
handing it down to Matt if he has an
interest in learning how to play it so
first thing I'll tell you about it is
that it's a little bit unusual not in
that it has five strings that's that's
pretty normal for most banjos although
you will find some authority for but
it's got a somewhat longer neck it's not
quite as long as a bass guitar but
pretty close
so most banjos that you would normally
see the neck would be about this long
and so it's much smaller like a regular
guitar and this one has a different
sound in part because of the longer neck
which which gives it a more sonorous
sound to it and also the smaller drum
compared to some other banjos so this is
an open G chord
yeah I see if it's actually stated -
[Music]
more or less and you notice that there's
four strings that play on the frets and
then there's this fifth string right
here that fifth string is what you call
a drone strike it's always playing the
same no matter what matter of fact if we
go here these are the same notes those
are the drones so there's a lot of ways
that the banjo can be tuned but the most
common tuning has this string and this
string five frets apart from each other
so that's five half steps right this D
and then e F G so this is both G and
then we go four steps to the next one so
G G haircut she already lost a little
bit of that one peg is a little bit
loose so it goes out of tune once in a
while then this one is three half steps
up so and then this is five - the drone
so an open G chord you're playing the
actual chord is she is the first and the
third
and then the octave right and then a low
D below there's all sorts of ways that
you can play the banjo one way is just
strum strum chords or you might just
strum two notes by themselves this song
intro you notice that I'm playing the
solo notes other strings as well so
that's another thing that you can do is
you could play scales if you wanted to
or just play single notes if you're
soloing on a banjo that's that's
typically what you would do something I
do a lot is picking or quite literally
plucking at them and there's a number of
ways that you can do that there are
things that are called rolls so we'll do
this on a C chord and you can see what
I'm doing here you pick on one finger
[Music]
probably the most basically then you can
have more complicated ones like this and
you can start improvising once missing
that sort of thing and doing all sorts
of
[Music]
and you can our braids strumming there's
all sorts of other things that are kind
of cool there's something called a claw
hammer that I'm not particularly good at
I haven't done for a while but I'll give
you a hint about how it sound so it's
like
[Music]
so there you have it there's all sorts
of other cool things that you can do
with a banjo but that's you know more or
less what you're confining yourself to
and if you're going to play the banjo
the first thing that you really need to
learn how to do besides tune it is learn
some chords and the chords you have to
do with where you're placing your
fingers on the fret board most of what I
do is actually in this area I don't get
too far up on the fret board because I
don't need too much of what I play isn't
actually banjo music it's guitar music
that I just play on the banjo so I can
sing it but you've got your G chord can
also play it up here then you have
variants like then you've got B
oftentimes you play B flat C C minor D D
is a very important chord for the banjo
a lot of songs use it you get your
straight deep
yeah descend between those three you've
got a lot of stuff covered then e is
someone's a little interesting I'm
Angela very important guitar chord
there's a straight D minor here's
[Music]
actually that's when I'm saying like
seventh and six and things like that
that's how you would change the chord
around to get a somewhat different sound
or way to play so where do we go from
there
back to G right so the first one but I
learned to play it was actually a song
that my dad used to sing when I was
little he bought this banjo back I think
in 1966 or 67 when he was a college
student folk music was really in back
that he happened to buy a banjo knows
his Vega thing here then at the time was
kind of common and now is kind of rare
so this is this is quite valuable and he
played it and Madden when he died he
passed it on to us in the family and I
was going to picked it up so one of the
songs that you would play is called the
MTA and Kingston Trio don't think came
up with it but they had
example of it you can find strumming
right
[Music]
just three chords there but it's a lot
more fun if you pick itself
[Music]
a little bit of struggling there as well
so and yeah I mean you could have a
teacher play it for you and play along
or sing along whatever you want to do
because
[Music]
and it goes on for a number Francis
after that as most folk songs do like I
said you can easily look it up and sing
it if you want to I'll play another song
from somebody who is from your state I
sometimes jokingly call him the Bard of
Indiana and you might recognize
[Music]
that's starting to ring a bell that
haven't been listening to some pop
country stuff that's the intro to a song
called paper and fire
[Music]
[Music]
so yeah that is probably enough I see
that we're already 10 minutes in and so
I don't want to take up too much of your
class time but glad that Matt asked me
to do a little presentation for you and
I hope that you got a taste of what the
be Angela looks like sounds like what
you might do with it
like I said remember keep in mind most
banjos that you're going to see not
quite as long as this one this is kind
of a special banjo so alright see you
later